Trade wars are a tricky business, even
when you think your partners aren't
playing fair. In a March poll, only 13 percent of
American adults thought that China had a
fair trade policy with the United States,
while 43 percent called it unfair. By a
margin of 44 to 23%, respondents to a
different question felt that the US
would be hurt more by a trade war than
China would be. In another March poll,
28% of registered voters agreed with
President Trump's assertion that a trade
war would be good for the United States
and easily won; 64 percent disagreed. In
our polarized political climate, 67
percent of Republicans, but only 7
percent of Democrats, thought it would be
good for US. The polls produced
conflicting impressions of support and
opposition to the aluminum and steel
tariffs themselves. But several new ones,
including an April ABC News/Washington
Post poll, show that more people think
the situation would be bad for jobs than
good by 49 to 36 percent.
What do you think about tariffs on China? Let us know
in your comments. Also, let us know what
other topics you'd like our scholars to
cover in 60 seconds, and be sure to like
and subscribe for more research and
videos from AEI.